記事の中で自分の手をいろんなメッセージがあって
記念としてね
で、だからうまくいかないと本当に損害する
だいぶ
スイちゃんスープいる?
中までする?
入れとくよ
3点目
それだったらうまく
うーん
で、その役割ね
もし生まれたからね
知っているから
これを100%ね
できるかわからないけども
比率が高いの自分
このまま
この上に乗せる
うーん
デルコートなんですね
そういうのは全然ない
やっとない
うーん
最後に今乗ったのがいつですか?
いつですか?
もう大きな
今乗ってないんですよ
また乗ろうと思ってるんだけど
ちょっとあの
本当ですか?
私の父とか先生方ってもう80代でしたよね
あのゆうささんなんてね
もう90代近くは何になって乗ってらっしゃってたから
本当?
まだ
でもいい馬だったら
うん
こういう
大丈夫です
うん
そう
つまり
えっと
乗る人は
うん
まだ
馬は
家を守る
あそう
まだ乗るんですか?
乗ろうと思ってるの
乗りたい気も
意欲があるということじゃないですか?
できると思う
何でかと言った?
90歳ぐらいでも乗ってる人いますよ
90歳ぐらい
うん
オリンピックだと
ポケツさんという方が75歳で
最高齢で出られましたんで
井上結子さんの事業を通してたよね
うん
馬が運動するんで
人間の筋力が衰えてもそれを補ってくれますので
うん
馬の方のトレーニングさえしとけば
できてれば
できるのは
うん
絶対やります
子は怖くないかな
うんうんうんうん
やすこともね
で、馬は怖いということを
においかな?
すぐに聞いて
そうか
確かにその
その
怖くない
子は
馬はちゃんと伝わるんですね
うん